la vaccination ça doit être un acte
libre ça doit être un acte libre ça doit
être un acte délibéré
chez les étudiants comme chez les
professionnels quoique encore chez les
professionnels vous l'avez évoqué on on
peut croire parfois plus plus exigeants
ce qui est certain c'est que un étudiant
par définition pour la plupart il n'a
pas de facteur de risque
on est bien d'accord de faire des formes
de co vide grave
en revanche un djeune il a probablement
des grands parents des parents des
proches en tout cas tout un tas de
personnes avec qui va être en contact et
ces personnes elles peuvent avoir des
facteurs de risque évidemment ça ne
supprime pas tous les risques
le fait d'être vacciner soi-même mais ce
qui est certain c'est que ça permet de
diminuer le risque
et quand on parle de personnes qu'on
aime qui nous sommes proches je crois
vraiment qu'il faut savoir le faire
absolument pas il faut pas cibler les et
fils en aide su pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que la
vaccination est ouverte pour notamment
les personnes les plus fragiles et que
malheureusement ces personnes les plus
fragiles ne se vaccinent pas tous
or nous ont dit qu'il faudrait que ces
personnes les plus fragiles se vaccine
puisque les jeunes ondes et on l'a dit
ont été impactés largement dans leur vie
sociale d'entre l'art vie étudiante dans
un esprit cana camaraderie qui
n'existait plus pendant plus d'un an
pendant le prêt d'un an et demi et donc
les jeunes ont assez souffert depuis
plus d'un an maintenant pour qu'on leur
oblige encore aujourd'hui à à faire plus
de charges
il ya une obligation en plus à ces
jeunes donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit
c'est que les jeunes ont déjà assez
souffert et c'était bien normal pour
bien évidemment protéger les plus
fragiles mais qu'aujourd'hui que la vie
de cette nation soit faite par ces
derniers par les plus fragiles pour que
pour que la crise ait appuyé ce qu'on
puisse pour qu'on puisse sortir cette
paix center
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut arrêter
d'infantiliser de décider d'une part et
d'infantiliser les étudiants il faut pas
oublier que ce sont des jeunes adultes
et n'oublions pas on parle de la
vaccination obligatoire pour ces
étudiants mais dans quel objectif encore
une fois c'est la réouverture les
universités dans leur ensemble et
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte que
des universités en france ont déjà fait
l'ensemble de par exemple mettre des des
tests disponibles sur les campus et
faire en sorte que les étudiants en
effet puisse se faire tester massivement
sur les campus et durant cette année et
ni de prise les politiques en gestation
d de la jeunesse des étudiants n'a pas
aidé la communication du ministère m'a
pris des contres vous savez le premier
la première conférence de presse de 2021
de du premier ministre a été faite sans
parler d'un seulement de la jeunesse et
des étudiants s'étaient le 7 janvier
chaque étudiant le le soc se souvient se
souvient de sa le 7 janvier une
conférence de presse qui n'a pas du tout
parlé une seule fois de la jeunesse
eh bien ça n'est pas forcément à ces
jeunes français de respecter aussi ses
responsables qui ont été pour le coup
paradoxalement irresponsable chez les
soignants il y a eu un décalage à la
vaccination aujourd'hui se font
massivement vacciner quoique quoique
typiquement dans les ehpad par exemple
en a souvent parlé ayant un déficit de
vaccination un des éléments qui
expliquent ce décalage à la vaccination
c'est aussi la communication du
gouvernement sur la politique vaccinale
qui a été excessivement mauvaise qui est
excessivement mauvaise et là il ya une
réaction qui est tout à fait saine qui
est tout à fait normal savez lorsque
vous faites confiance à votre
gouvernement aux pouvoirs publics qu'ils
vous disent faites vous vacciner
prenez ce vaccin voilà comment ça va
s'organiser au fond à partir du moment
où c'est lisible
vous pouvez faire confiance
malheureusement la politique pendant
longtemps politique vaccinale
elle a été et la politique de lutte
contre l'épidémie en général elle était
totalement illisible mais la conséquence
elle est simple c'est que quand vous
avez un espèce de brouhaha
une cacophonie comme ça et bien la
réaction légitime qu'on a tous c'est de
dire au fond puisque je peux pas leur
faire confiance
je fais comme bon me semble et ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il ya eu une espèce
de yo yo yo yo scientifique et un yoyo
même morale et sentimental presse qui a
fait qu'à la fin on a dit mais à qui
faire confiance et ça ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de mal le croit je pense que le
délaissement l'oubli le presque parfois
le mépris du gouvernement face à la
jeunesse durant cette crise sanitaire a
tout simplement poussé les étudiants à
s'en désintéresser
c'est une c'est une évidence c'est une
réalité et on voit bien aujourd'hui la
gestion de la crise chaotique par le
gouvernement actuel a bien évidemment
poussé les étudiants sur la touche de la
politique je pense que tous aient tous
ces facteurs peuvent expliquer
l'abstention mais sur sur la jeunesse en
particulier
en effet la gestion chaotique du
gouvernement n'a pas aidé à faire
revenir les jeunes d'horizons sa venue
en france pour tous les travailleurs
ces 48 heures maximum de travail par
semaine et c'est la même chose en europe
lorsque vous lui dites monsieur le
ministre il faut absolument faire
respecter cette loi on ne demande pas de
droits nouveaux
parce qu'il ya un danger il ya un danger
pour nous qui avons déjà tout donné et
c'était déjà présents avant et il ya un
danger pour nos patients
et bien la réponse du ministre est clair
il nous dit je ne décompterait pas le
temps de travail donc aujourd'hui on
peut travailler en france sans aucun
problème en tant que médecin jusqu'à 90
heures voire plus de 100 heures en une
semaine se mettre en danger et mettre en
danger les patients
et lorsque vous avez ces deux éléments
qui s'entrechoquent
ce discours extrêmement mélioratif
presque on a parlé de donner des
médailles aux soignants mais j'avais
dire la seule médaille que les soignants
attendent du gouvernement de cattier
jeunes médecins attendent du
gouvernement c'est de faire respecter la
loi de la république je crois que c'est
la moindre des choses qu'on puisse
demander à des représentants de l'état
mais aujourd'hui même ça on nous le
refuse donc évidemment
bout est extrêmement extrêmement amer